the other day Brent came in and made the
big announcement that he and his wife
Kaitlyn are now swingers full-on
swingers they're not soft swingers
they're hardcore swingers and Brent came
in here not bragging but just saying
look I'm now in the swinging world I
want to share that with the audience and
I was grateful for that truly you came
in and said you didn't believe a word of
it and you thought Brent was full of
[ __ ] and it caused some fireworks so you
got to hear this well Julie goes to the
wrestling event Robyn mm-hmm what is the
sign you were holding up on TV Saturday
night I went to Ring of Honor at Madison
Square Garden oh good I'm glad you're
here Brent you need to hear this this is
on the wrestling something to do with
Brent yes sign said Brent is lying
pretty [ __ ] up thing to do to be
honest that was I saw that was like holy
[ __ ] Julie's gone to another level it's
really [ __ ] up once we sign breath is
lying and the announcer says Brent is
aligned oh maybe I wasn't lying and none
of that was funny what was agreed you
know the idea that he got a sign Brent's
lying millions of people watch wrestling
that's called cheap Heat right
cheap Heat that's called cheap Heat yeah
when you're not being creative at all
right and you're just getting cheap Heat
that's what he's doing I'll make you a
deal I will admit publicly on the air
that you're telling the truth if you
just thank me for making you guys huge
stars in swing in in in wrestling terms
I'll respond to your deal you can take
your deal turn it sideways shine it up
and shove it up your ass
wow wow those heavy he's trying to now
hurt me personally and professionally
he knows that a lot of people in this
business listen to this show and he
knows it's gonna get on this show and
he's trying to hurt me Michael really
still believe that Brent was lying or
you just busting his balls listen I will
say this God there are two
in the story that bug me okay okay one
is people when he walks into the
swingers club people going oh [ __ ]
surely you were right [ __ ] that that I
don't believe happened it happens all
the time in fact Brent you say surely is
hated by the swinging community he is no
idea really yeah all right surely
decides to swing he probably couldn't
know if they probably wouldn't him in
right he said quote I'm a pariah you're
swinging community so you think he was
lying about people many of you I think
you put Phil in a couple spots to make
the story sound better your name on that
of course I love it right okay I'm just
making that up [ __ ] you shuli I'm just
and then the fact he's getting so angry
about it like like what do you get so
angry about you guys because you're in
here you're in here calling what you are
calling me a liar yeah are you gonna be
making other signs when other invent
something I don't think so the mood just
struck me at the moment I didn't know
what to do cheapy I was working for the
show or is he congratulations on your
big sign at Ring of Honor honor yes
patchouli how well do you know it
yeah I'm 44 I got to keep it quiet I
don't want him to know that it's fake he
still believes it's real
well alright good for you surely uh mr.
surely everybody